[Music]
excuse me miss why are you dressed for
laser tag
oh boy you guys don't have any clue do
you I'm here to stop the shapeshifters
that are infiltrating your planet
[Music]
connection
Wow Captain Marvel you know you're
glowing right doctor show these boys how
we do it
you ready higher further faster babies
faster
try to keep up
hey everybody its charlie we got a whole
bunch of new Captain Marvel footage to
break down in a brand new Avengers
end-game promo for their shiny new armor
that's right it's gonna look so awesome
so we'll start with the Captain Marvel
footage then we'll talk about Avengers
endgame there's a new round of the
Amazon giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite Iron Man armor on the video so
the whole deal with this new Captain
Marvel promos so just trying to give you
a better idea for the tone of the film
like some of the jokes because early on
she was just a little more hardcore Kree
they were giving you like the military
version of Carol Danvers before you got
to know what her personality was
actually like so this just plays a lot
on the comedy of the two days from
retirement Nick Fury like he's Danny
Glover in lethal weapon I was two days
away from retirement in what's actually
going on on this scroll ship they give
you a much better look at the scrolls we
seen a couple quick shots of them before
but this is obviously just showing you a
much bigger team that's sitting on that
spaceship in orbit that's been cloaked
during the course of the film so you can
tell from all this footage that a lot of
this is gonna be Carol Danvers doing
really crazy stuff as she becomes comic
book Captain Marvel in Nick Fury
reacting Talbot like you know you're
glowing right which is probably this
corresponding scene that we've seen in
all the earlier trailers when she goes
full binary before she goes into outer
space and starts blowing all these
spaceships up which is at full power but
I love the way that Nick Fury greets her
in this scene here this is probably when
they first meet and he gives her that
laser tag joke like what are you doing
here why you look so crazy he probably
just thinks that she's just another
weirdo on the streets of LA like all the
other weirdos during the 80s like what
kind of crazy drugs has she been doing
and then she tries to give him the
speech where it gets even crazier like
oh you have no idea there's a Secret
Invasion there are aliens that are
trying to take over your government so
for Nick Fury it just keeps getting
weirder and weirder until probably this
moment here where you seen with the ice
pack looking at the body of this girl
this is probably what turns her around
like oh I need to believe all this like
you see him earlier and those other
trailers where he's fumbling with his
pager talking about I am with the target
talking about Captain Marvel because at
this point in the film they still think
that she's kind of crazy it's not until
they actually revealed that the scroll
is actually someone pretending to be a
SHIELD agent that Nick Fury is like holy
crap this is all going on they confirm
that the D cloaking ship and orbit we've
been seeing since the very first trailer
is the Skrulls ship in all this footage
of her trying to escape kicking all
these scrolls asses is after this moment
where you see her in that upside-down -
bye
they recently explained this is just the
scrolls trying to extract information
from her brain she breaks out though you
can see how her hands are bound in these
giant large cylinders immobilizing her
she breaks out but the funny thing is is
that she just rips them right out of
their housings but she doesn't bust them
off of her hands so she's running around
bludgeoning them with this giant
cylinder still stuck on her head then
there are more a couple shots of her and
Nick Fury through the film after they
steal this proto Quinn jet looking ship
from the shield military base Nick Fury
looking like he's fully team captain
marvel at this point screaming and
excitement then you give the shot of him
on the scroll ship joking about her
glowing like I said this probably
corresponds to this other shot where she
goes full binary I've already talked
about Captain Marvel or the mysterious a
lack of Captain Marvel and all the
Avengers and game trailers don't be
surprised if they treat her in the
Avengers and GameTrailers the same way
they treated Superman and all the
Justice League trailers so what will
happen is as Captain Marvel is hitting
theaters the first week in March we'll
probably get another Avengers endgame
trailer around that time it's about a
month away after that is probably when
we'll start seeing her appear in the
trailer I think they're just holding off
so that people have a chance to see the
Captain Marvel movie to get the intro to
her character so you know what she's
like in the MCU before she shows up and
avengers endgame trailers but they did
the exact same thing with Superman in
Justice League we all knew he was gonna
be during the film he was gonna come
back but they waited till the last
possible minute to put him in one of the
Justice League trailers so speaking of
Avengers endgame we have a shiny new
armor promo to break down this is one of
the better ones too because it's super
high-res and it's official because it's
coming from one of the licensed partners
in the United States in the stuff you
see on the merchandise that they still
in and around the film like on the
popcorn tubs or like the stuff that you
buy when you go to the theater that all
winds up being pretty accurate to what
their costumes look like during the film
so we'll just break down all the changes
going left to right so Thor looks like
he's the only one in the picture that
seems like he's wearing the exact same
armor from Avengers infinity war so I'm
assuming for now unless we get more
evidence that that just means that the
other Avengers get multiple costume
changes during the film in Thor only
gets the one quantum armor a costume
change and they're still trying to hold
back on including that unofficial promos
so everyone else in their shiny
brand-new costumes starting with
man's very og comic book looking gold
armor for some reason which we can only
guess this is being called the Iron Man
mark 85 in the press you remember that
the infinity war armor is called the
Iron Man mark 50 so what happened to the
other 34 armors between this and this
the only couple ways to logically
explain that if they pull another Iron
Man three series of quick cuts or a time
jump where he spends a period of time
iterating a bunch of new armors that
they then pay off in some sort of Iron
Man Armory scene or if you really want
to be optimistic in hope maybe pull off
another similar scene from the end of
Iron Man 3 where he unleashes them all
at the same time kill for some armor
right now you're right we need backup
yeah a bunch you know
this is that yep
are those yeah
any number of those scenarios would be
cool I don't care how they get to this
it just looks really badass so I want to
see more footage of this in an actual
trailer eventually so unless he
MacGyver's himself another different set
of armor inside the guardianship with
nebula here we'll call this the space
cave for now just because the scenes
very obvious reference to the cave and
Iron Man one when he was making the Iron
Man Mark one suit we don't have enough
footage right now to know what he's
doing besides trying to MacGyver his way
out of this situation so if he just
fixes the guardianship to find a way to
give it enough power to limp to a nearby
a spaceport
or get all the way back to earth it
seems more like the call to action for
him that takes him out of his slump here
in all the earlier trailers when it
seems like he's super defeated and he's
getting ready to lay down and die
something happens he remembers he's a
genius and he can save himself in that
high of the moment of inspiration just
carries him forward through the rest of
the plot and gives him the ideas he
needs to make this new Iron Man mark 85
armor we talk all day about Iron Man in
Avengers endgame they even released a
new synopsis that teases some funny
consequences to the ways that the
Avengers are going about fixing the
universe the new one just reads after
the devastating events of Avengers
infinity war the universe is in ruins
due to the efforts of the mad Titan
Thanos with the help of the remaining
allies the Avengers must assemble once
more in order to undo the noses actions
and restore order to the universe once
and for all no matter what consequences
may be in store so we just imply some
very ominous consequences to what the
Avengers are doing with the quantum
energy in the quantum realm but the
butterfly effect is probably the best
analogy like you change one minor thing
to try and fix everything
but it causes a lot of unintended
consequences some of them really bad at
down the road Captain America's armor
seems pretty self-explanatory is just a
refreshed version of his Captain America
Civil War armor with the scales exposed
cool costume Easter Egg though you may
have spotted during infinity war when
Captain America shows up during the film
he's been wearing his civil war armor
for the past few years but because of
his disillusionment with the government
and his status as a fugitive
he's darkened the star and he hasn't
been repairing the armor so just chalk
it up to life on the run they wanted him
to look like things had been really bad
for him in that time since Civil War
visibly broken down mentally broken down
but when you see the torn armor up close
you can spot the comic book scales
underneath that top
lair so it seems like he just cleans up
this Civil War armor and removes the
damage top layer portions exposing all
of the scales the Black Widow costume
doesn't look that much different just a
little sleeker stealth suit with her
gauntlets and her stun batons but the
very very noticeable difference is that
she has the longer red hair that she's
grown back out with the blonde mix of
the haircut from infinity war all the
concept art that we've seen in the
behind the scenes pictures this is the
clearest indicator of a time jump just
the time it would take her to grow that
hair out Hawkeye and his Ronin costume
as we've already seen in all the
trailers slightly better look at him the
new haircut it's pretty close to the
Ronin hawkeye costume from the comics I
already did a video after infinity war
about why Hawkeye would become Ronin and
be doing all this after the snap it's
all about his family they made such a
big stink about him being two days away
from retirement like I said Nick Fury
Danny Glover in lethal weapon two days
away from retirement all he wanted to do
in Avengers age of Ultron was retired to
his secret farm so that he could be with
his secret family that none of the other
Avengers knew about which is where he
would have been chilling out until the
snap so he probably had the exact same
scene that ant-man did at the end of
ant-man and the wasp only he was sitting
there in a room watching his family
turned to dust
not totally understanding what's going
on then all these scenes of him and the
Avengers endgame trailer in Japan in the
Ronin Gear it's just his way of dealing
with the grief so like you saw that
during the Superbowl trailer all them
trying to deal with their respective
grief in different ways but then we got
to talk about this very banner looking
version of Professor Hulk in the shiny
new spandex armor it's kind of armor but
Hulk doesn't really need armor so I'm
guessing this is just more of a special
fabric spandex style that stretches when
he grows and contracts when he goes back
to banner form so that he doesn't keep
shredding his clothes every single time
he Hulk's out the reason why there's so
much purple in it is just a comic-book
reference to hooks classic purple pants
but look at his face and look at his
hair it's a real haircut in like banners
streaked with a little grey on the sides
hooks hair normally looks crazy like
this and it's not gray at all I've
already done a few videos about what the
Russos have said about hulks arc through
infinity war an Avengers end game is
mostly about the relationship between
Banner and the Hulk they explained that
Hoek wouldn't come back during infinity
war because
he was protesting banners treatment of
him because banner would only let Hulk
out when he wanted Hulk to fight for him
so it's funny to think that Hulk has
dreams of his own like I have things
that I want let me out let me be a
person too so professor Hulk in the
comics is just the perfect fusion of
Banner and the Hulk so it just confirms
that Hulk and Banner worked their [ __ ]
out sometime during Avengers endgame and
get down to some serious smashing the
other really cool thing about Professor
Hulk is that he can speak intelligently
because it's banner speaking with Hulk's
voice just based on the way they're
presenting these costumes it seems like
they're supposed to be the main versions
of the costumes for most of the film so
they wear those white quantum suits that
we've been seeing all the images of it
might just be for a short period during
the film but remember how we keep
talking about all those weird risk
devices in all the pictures they have
them in these scenes from the original
battle of New York in the first Avengers
film they have them in this promo art
with the white suits in Black Widow
in this new promo images with their new
costumes has one on her wrist as well so
I've seen a couple theories about what
these actually are and I do agree that
they probably have something to do with
the way they use quantum energy so
everybody post all your reactions for
the new Captain Marvel footage in the
new avengers endgame armor in the
comments below and what will happen is
there's a whole bunch of other Marvel
stuff that drop in a bunch of DC
trailers I'll try to get to that stuff
as fast as possible but let me know if
there's any special Marvel videos that
you guys want me to make so click here
for all that really cool Avengers
endgame trailer footage and click here
for more brand-new Game of Thrones
season 8 promos thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]